hello I hope you can hear me because I
cannot tell if you can hear me welcome
uh there is still room upstairs
so I see two places
three stairs
also thank you for being here uh I see a
lot of people up curently interested in
what grpc is in net are you looking to
replace your rest apis with
something or you do not know yet cool uh
today we're going to do a a deep dive
into what net grpc has to offer uh
you're going to see a lot of Code by the
end uh and you also going to have access
to the repository that I'm using so you
can uh you able to run it yourself so um
about
me or not about me yeah because
apparently Windows 11 before a talk it's
awesome for the first time so don't do
that um my name is dku I'm from Romania
uh I'm a software architect uh and AET
consultant I do a lot of work around the
communities so I organize a user group
and a small small small conference in
Romania I teachnet and I blog but I
recently been hacked so I don't have
blog there remove the DNS um and
recently it has just been published uh
web API for beginners so if you know
someone that tries to switch from I
don't know desktop development to web
that uh might be the book for uh for the
person so uh apis right because I'm
assuming I'm not allowed to assume
actually so I'm going to ask how many of
you are doing uh
apis cool a lot of you all of you so
you're work working on their web
environments with rest apis right so we
have to talk about rest since we're
talking about
grpc uh and some people are uh saying
that grpc should be like in a fight with
rest apis which is not really the case
so how many of you are doing like fully
rest apis following all the Sixx
constraints with hate and all the
ceremonies around it right how many of
you a few of you
nice so what I realized during the years
is that uh developers including me we're
just following a few of the guidelines
that R rest tried to impose basically
rest tried to impose um The Common Sense
around HTTP basically forcing us to use
headers the right verbs the right status
code and such like that well um we
cannot talk about apis rest and fancy
things without talking about a monolith
because that's where we started it and
apparently with the modular monolith
that's where we are going back so uh
monolith I'm going to make a full
disclaimer here um I really enjoyed
working with monoliths because
everything was very easy you had a huge
amount of source code if ever wanted
something in there you can you could go
ahead instantiate that class use it
everything was there and another pork of
using a monolith was that long build
times I remember uh with bad Hardware
build a solution that was huge took a
significant time so I could go away and
grab a coffee and enjoy uh the start of
the work yeah so uh the Cons with the
monolith is that people say that it's
hard to scale I mean you can scale it of
course but but not without significant
uh costs it has bad uh bad bad user
experience it has low high low times so
for example if you have components in
your monolith that are not used you'll
still need those to be working in order
for the other components to work yeah so
uh it's easy to start with a monolit but
you have a single code base for
everything which is bummer yeah so big
bill from the cloud providers so then
people started to realize that well it's
not that cool to work with those uh the
we started to have in net at least a
framework like ASP MVC when we had
server site uh that rendered HTML but
still it was everything around an onion
architecture everything was
self-contained and then fast forward in
a few years we had a front end written
in whatever JS your preference and a
back end that has a database where sever
databases and
moving on the future is distributed
because now that easy application that
consuming that was consuming a back end
so an API now it became something like
this we have several apis consumed by
the same front end and then the front
end or the back end API consumed another
uh backend API and we we started to have
things that are not so easy to maintain
anymore and work a straight but we
needed those because uh due to the
increase of uh of the web right now our
user users are not willing to expect
that hey uh this takes 10 seconds to
load no they will be gone before you
have time to figure it out so now we
have things like this or at least we
could have like node.js talking with a
go talking with the net core API and
stuff like that which is a poly polyglot
environment but we have rest for
everything right and as we see uh rest
is is not used as it's supposed to be so
rest is in a way the Common Ground
between any other uh language that we
could use inside our system so what is
wrong with rest where basically there's
nothing wrong with rest as long as we
use it for the right purpose because if
we have customer facing apis to the
outside world we should use it yeah it's
not there to be replaced but as many of
us started doing
microservices well the first thing when
you start micros service architecture or
you maybe I know you have a monolith and
you want to split it so the first thing
that you do so at least it's what I did
what say okay I'm going to extract this
part I'm going to put it somewhere else
it's going to be a new service and that
service will serve data to whever want
uh to get data from so what do you do
you create a HTTP client because that's
the first thing that you want to do yeah
create an HTTP client get data from
there use it and so on and so forth
we're not talking about messaging system
because those are an entirely different
story um but the incremental way of
basically extracting microservices from
a monolith is to is simple like this
step by step yeah HTTP clients then move
it in a messaging architecture and stuff
like that yeah so incremental and evolve
your architecture and you'll say that
there is nothing wrong with rest we're
going to use
rest until God knows when but there are
other Technologies out there that we
need to be aware of and one of them is
remote procedure calls and this is a
concept that was burn around since the
70s and as you see there are a few
Concepts that tend to resurface from
time to time so RPC as a as a thing as a
concept will make a system um behave
like monolith in a transpar a
transparent uh way so for example if we
look at this code
you'll see that we have an order uh we
have an API or uh whatever service
called called create order payment
status we process the payment for uh
that order and then if the payment is
successful we arrange the shipping for
it yeah looking at this code it looks
like it's in the same system I mean if
you're looking at this you're not
necessarily understanding that you're
basically doing HTTP calls to somewhere
to a API yeah so the code is very
familiar for a developer it has a column
method approach you're not using HTTP
clients to create new requests and to
get data from so uh
basically whenever we're calling one of
these method we're going over the
network we're getting data back we get
the result from there and we do the same
every single time we're we're calling
such method so RPC as a generic concept
will make the code look local familiar
to the developer yeah you won't have to
orchestrate anything you do not have
HTTP clients to be uh obvious that
you're doing a network call so it has
this call a method get some data or send
some data by calling a method and it's
prone to errors because it's transparent
to us but its primary goal is to make
the network communication transparent is
like it's not there yeah so what if now
we have like a distributed system like a
monolith and we do not care uh it's the
consumer's job to retry in case
something bad happens is the consumer's
job to take care of whatever full
tolerance and
resiliency uh it's in your system yeah
so fast forward in a few years we get
grpc and obviously G comes from Google
yeah it started uh in 2001 so it's not a
new technology uh of course started
internally uh at Google and then after a
few years they open sourced it uh and
then fast forward a few years 2019 we
got it in net because grpc is basically
a specification that was implemented by
many languages uh and net was laid to
the party so it it has been around in
Java it has been around in go but net
got it in 2019 with a lot of Errors
around it the tooling was not good but
now a lot of things have have improved
so
grpc uh it's contract based uh as we
will see you we will create a contract
that will be the Common Ground between a
consumer and the
server and by using this we will have no
more code references so we won won't
have like right click add the project
reference to a specific package that
lives inside the same solution to be
able to use that so that won't be there
anymore the single thing that is common
to any um consumer and any server that
implements
grpc it's uh the protocol buffer files
that we will see it uses http2 so
basically if you're still using HTTP
1 nope sorry it's not for you it deits
the purpose it uses http2 which makes it
faster and du the the way the http2
works uh it allow you to have uh full
duplex communication like a client in a
server streaming in the same collection
which is
awesome and also it has another thing
which is uh protuff serialization it
works with binary data so no more Json
no more uh things to decode and human
read for us and of course it's available
in many languages so if you have a
component in your system that is written
in node that needs to get data from net
or from java this is good for you yeah
so because you have this contract that
it's known uh by every single language
and another thing that is very cool is
that that it does code generation out of
the box the compiler the protoc C
compiler will generate C classes C types
for us and we will be able to just use
those so if you look at the traditional
client request um so a client requests
something from a server and the server
process the request and responds back
now in we're introducing something in
between which is this this interface
called Proto written in protocol buffer
syntax so there's this so we're
basically interrupting the communication
with making the client aware of what the
server has to offer and the server is
basically exposing what it has to offer
to the client yeah so the protocol file
looks very easy it has a funky syntax uh
funky given the fact that uh it's very
similar
to soap it's it's rather uh
declarative uh there are extensions for
visual studio and Jet brains Raider and
um Visual Studio code that help you with
uh intelligence and stuff like that so
first thing that you'll have to do is to
Define that hey I'm using this uh
protocol buffers 3 version of the syntax
there is also a version two that is not
advisable to be used um and you're
saying Hey I want to generate a
namespace in C called my first RPC and
then I want to generate a package called
Fibonacci the package is used for
interop
interoperability so if you have a node
talking with the uh net core that will
be the Nam space that you going to use
and then you just go ahead and Define
your services so services are the actual
implementation for um for the specific
um types so service called fibo it's an
RPC operation called compute Fibonacci
that get the requested number and
Returns the Fibonacci result it's rather
straightforward say hey I have this it's
an RPC method call like this it has an
input and it has an output right and the
Funky thing is that you cannot have like
a method without parameters in grpc you
will have to have a type that has
nothing in it but you will still have to
have a type yeah same happens for the
result yeah it returns something even
though that's something is empty it has
to have a bit of
memory um moving on WE Define messages
these messages become C classes C types
that we can use in our C code and we can
define properties using the types that
uh protocol buffer uh buffers expose for
us uh for example in requested number we
have an in32 called number equals one
well the equals one it's not an
assignment we're not assigning to filled
uh the value of one we're basically
saying that the number is the
first uh property in the binary string
so if we'd have more we would add more
and just equal two three and stuff like
that or if we want to remove something
for versioning purposes we'll just skip
a few numbers
and um add something more so uh some
other things around grpc is that it
supports grpc modes and these modes are
basically
um some people are called them modes or
method types it's basically types of
requests that you can do with uh with
JPC you have unary server streaming
client streaming and bir directional
this happens uh these types can happen
over a single TCP connection like we
used to In traditional uh web and they
look very nice uh so unary we have a
client that initiates a communication to
a server that implements the grpc
protocol buffer file and then the server
responds back how you would Define such
thing just by simply calling uh I have
an RPC method named uh compute Fibonacci
gets an input uh request number and
returns a Fibonacci result for the next
ones the the client still has to
initiate the communication
so uh the client Say Hey I want
something from you I want this method so
it opens the communication Channel with
the server and the server will be able
to send in the same connection uh
several chunks of data so one single
connection and several chunks of data
and if you were to Define such a method
you would just put the stream keyword to
the part that it's streaming so in our
case if the server
streams we have to add the stream
keywords towards the end and um that
would be it if we're on the client to
stream we'll just go ahead and add the
stream keyword to the part that uh is in
for example the client opens a
communication Channel sends a lot of
data and it will get one response back
yeah so think about scenarios where I
don't know you want to upload L large
files you can upload those in chunks
over single TCP connection that uh that
is opened uh you can also collect data
from different servers uh and it's uh
here if you want to Define this is just
by adding uh the stream keyword towards
the part that is supposed to be
many bir directional is a combination of
the previous two just add the stream
keyword to the then to the end and
you're done yeah so let's see some
code first of all going to make sure
that this
is
visible uh okay so I have here a lot of
uh small small projects one of them
being a server project
that has even a lot of files that
they're not necessarily interesting for
you right now but you can look at the
code and um see for yourself so if you
want to build a service it's similar as
you would uh build a web API you simply
go and say hey I want to add a new
project to the solution and that project
will have a
grpc see there is already a
template and you give it a name and you
click next and basically accept what the
default interface shows you and you'll
have a running working um service yeah
so um what you can have is a program CS
that's the same program CS that we all
know from any other types of uh projects
web API MVC and stuff like that is there
the here is the place where you wire
things uh you have an app setting Json
that's there and it won't go anywhere uh
you can of course add packages if you
want and as you'll see one of the
packages that is uh already installed
it's called grpc SP netcore so it
already has all the functionality that
you need for implementing
this and it has a folder where
supposedly your protocol files will live
if you have uh several of them and
another folder called services that that
is basically the actual code the
implementation for what you define so
what we'll have here is a great uh is
the example pretty much that I showed
you already a surface defined called say
hello gets a hello request and returns a
hello reply these are types that you can
use to populate and uh and use but for
whatever operation you define here you
will have to give an implementation in
the corresponding service so
supposedly the service will have every
operation that you define that you want
to expose like in here so once you go
there and implement it you'll see that
you have I'm going to just delete this
for for a bit and say hi I want to pop
to override
this and it will show you what you have
in the protocol file available for
overwriting yeah so in here we have the
say hello
and inside to say hello I'm going to
undo this because I don't want you to
see me like mistyping so what we have we
have an input so it's a type of hello
request and the second parameter that
you cannot get rid of so by default grpc
comes with this second parameter that
you'll have to mock whenever you're
doing a unit or integration test for
this this server called context is a
wrapper and it wraps the grpc context
and it allows you to have access to the
HTTP context on top of it so thinking
about this we have like the normal HTTP
context that we use in web API or MVC
apps and behind it we have the small
grpc calls Yeah so basically we have two
levels of headers of metadata that we
can um can access yeah so once you have
this you'll have to make sure that the
services are ready registered here see
that we have like a map grpc service and
this is the service name so the platform
will take care of instantiating and
access uh give you access to this and of
course make sure that you have at grpc
middleware to this so basically a grpc
service is nothing more fancy than a
console app than the web API has yeah so
this is pretty much
it uh what else I have to show you this
one uh by looking in the project file
per se you'll have here an item group
this is helpful if you want to debug
things because usually when you add a
protocol uh file uh it's not added in
here by default so you have to make it
available to the uh project so you will
have to add another line for the protuff
and to include the path where it can
find these protocol files um the deal is
that as a best practice whenever you're
having grpc service is uh you will work
with this protocol files to share around
so if you have service a talking with
service B uh the Common Ground between
them is the protocol file and the
tendency would be to have a copy of the
Proto file in service a and a copy of
the protocol file in service B which is
an anti pattern and a bad practice um
what I advise you to do is to have a
separate rapper separate folder where
you keep the protocol files and you will
have only one source of Truth and just
pointing out the the C project path to
that folder in order to make those uh
discoverable yeah so once you add this
it's a project that it's up and running
with the demo with the small demo so
moving to our
example we have a server that in our
case will expose all four methods and we
will be able to use those so we haveo
hello say hello request uh one that's
returns a stream of responses a stream
of requests uh and uh bir directional
yeah as you've seen I'm I re name this
as being the request to make it more
aware U to make you more aware towards
the HTTP client server a request
response pattern cool and once we have
this uh we can run it and we can can
call it so we're able to call it and to
test every single part of it just by uh
using I'm using using console apps
because that's the best interface for
some cases has the best UI um and you
say that hey um I'm going to have a
channel a channel is like a higher um
ground where you can configure things
like like authentication compression
things um response sizes request sizes
for grpc and then uh we get this Channel
and pass it in to a client greater gter
client
and if I am going to have 12 in it I'm
going to show you that this is very
funky and lowlevel and modifiable but
not advisable to be
modified um this is the code generation
part that grpc does Yeah so basically it
will generate a St static partial class
called grer uh containing the service
name and everything that we we defined
in the protocol file like in here yeah
it has p a package called grd it has the
name SP space server and stuff like that
so it generates a few things for us one
of them being the greater gritter client
yeah so we're able now to use this
client uh to issue requests so this
client it will show us what are the
methods in the interface in the protocol
file and we'll just look at the
signature populate fields in there and
just call them and the easiest thing
that uh I can do is to show you an
instance of the server
running
sorry not this but this one so uh in
here I'm going toet build net run uh the
server and you'll see that it's simply
the console that expects us to make
requests I also enabled I think debug or
Trace logging just to show that how it
discovers things it discovers to say
hello server stream client stream and
bir directional so all the four methods
that we we have in the interface and
then uh you see that it listens on this
port one from HTTP and one for
https yeah so uh it waits for us to do
requests and on the right hand side uh I
will run the console app yeah so I'm
going to do like doet run for
it see I'm sending this value an
exclamation mark and I get hello back
with this value from Local Host 5000
server so I also added the port in there
because I want to demo um some other
things and one thing I'm going to do on
the server side in here is to show you
what kind of requests are made so it
says it's an http2 request it's a post
request so the thing with grpc is that
you have only post no get no put no
nothing just post it sends things uh and
you'll see that this in here it's kind
of an URL but it's only the path towards
the operation that we exposed it's of M
type application
grpc uh and uh it returned a 200 status
code remember whatever you're seeing
here here it's at the HTTP level it's
the status code that we all know it's
the M types that are available this is
top level HTTP okay so this is
unary so if we look
here um created a Channel created a
client by passing the channel sending an
object this request that we defined in
protocol buffer file and simply calling
the method and writing it back into the
console that's it nothing more it's
nothing fancy yeah so let's look at the
other um types the server is still up
and running we don't need it to uh to do
something uh special uh we're going to
test the client streaming the client
streaming means that the client will be
the one that will send a lot of things
chunks of things to the server and it
will get back one response so let's do
this net
run and as a
result you should see that the server
side is like writing
things it takes a while I don't know how
um what number I did I did a for Loop
that I'm writing it to the console say
that it's done so this is the last
um okay so the server site got a lot of
things it says that it executed
endpoints it got values stuff like that
and
the hello I'm not moving too much at
least okay uh so the client said okay
the the server received this value as
the less value looking at the code for
it the client streaming uh is the same
so it's basically creating a channel and
passing that channel to a client that is
generated for us and it's simply using
uh uses um a try catch and write thing
to the request stream so I'm going to
create the client stream and I'm going
to have a for Loop that goes to this
value and then I'm simply creating new
types and sending and writing them Asing
to the request stream this this might
look funky at first but uh in the end
it's just having a connection open in
which you just write until you're done
writing so that's the concept behind it
and then you respond you wait the
response from the server and the server
will uh will respond with only one thing
of type response writing this to the
console and you're done yeah so one
thing I want to mention here uh
beforehand is that
um try catch and you'll see here that we
have RPC exception so whenever something
bad happens uh in uh grpc service you're
catching or you're throwing exception
and it will throw exception and those
types are RPC exception that will have
status codes yeah one thing to to
remember that those status codes are not
part of the 63 one that we're used to at
HTTP level these are grpc status codes
and you'll see there are 16 of them like
aborted not found already exist data
loss deadline exceeded Fair
precondition stuff like that so you can
use that to basically uh cover ground
around the scenarios that you have so if
you if you say hey uh I want to make
this grpc call but if I do not get back
um in a timely manner in two seconds the
response then this means that you can
throw away the connection it's fine
close it I don't need that anymore yeah
so how do you do and treat uh exception
is just by looking at the status codes
related to the grpc that comes back yeah
so this is one thing that uh it's worth
mentioning testing the other part still
the servers is are running and we're
going to do the server stream which
means that the server will push back a
lot of things to the client and we're
seeing things in the client side I'm
going to do net run and run not X
run see Ser it's the same approach for
Loop and I'm taking the I and writing it
back so the servers
streams so we're streaming like string
things but we also could stream like
data types complex types and
stuff and we're here yeah and the same
happen Happ s with the grpc part uh the
bir directional one sorry if I run this
console that
is net
run you'll see that you get both um the
client sends an i in a loop going to 10
this time and it receives back the same
responses like send us the the server
the server receives this why does this
happen okay
yeah so it sends an i and gets back the
same eyes uh the thing is that the the
messages are not in not ordered are
happening in the same connection but
they're not ordered it just happens to
be order in my situation but don't
expect it to be order the fact is
that when you're sending like a
production in data there yeah you'll
have data that supposedly it's not part
of the whole like chunk of
bites of data from a huge file or stuff
like that you'll have to have way in
which you say oh okay so this goes here
and this goes there to make the hole so
um there are a few things tweaks that
you'll have to to do if you have such a
scenario so we're done with this so
getting back to our
code um there are a few things that I
need to mention before we we we continue
and those things are related to
some things that grpc should do good I'm
not going to open this um because it
will take a lot of time to display there
so first thing to keep in mind is that
St status codes at the grpc level are
not status codes as we know in HTTP in
web API uh everything that we can throw
and treat is an RPC exception what kind
of RPC exception it's up to us to
basically uh address we can have uh
request headers response
headers that is not what we used to know
we still have the HTTP ones yeah so we
have HTTP headers except content type
and Customs ones custom ones that we can
add but at the grpc call we don't have
that anymore due to the fact The http2
Works differently yeah so what we have
is a thing called
trailers that is basically a key value
pair that we add for hgr PC response and
we can have a look at that by looking at
our
service where I added an example for it
yeah so I already told you that the
server call context the second parameter
that you get allows you to access things
at the HTTP level and one of them being
the request headers http1 yeah uh and
then you can get values like the user
agent if you're interested in I don't
know culture content up type stuff like
that and also you can do things like
this you can extract from there the
context that we know and from there we
can access like the user if we want we
can access the claims of the user we can
use auth authorization authentication
details um but this time we have two
places where we can add authentication
one of them being at the HTTP level we
all know about that but we also can
authenticate each individual GPC call
that happens somehow inside the single
um the single G the single HTTP
connection and we can do that at two
levels globally and per call a thing
that we didn't have before with web
API so getting back to uh what I wanted
to show you is that per call we can add
things that are called response
trailers and these are things like um
key Val value pairs called metadata
entries that you can add in there and
you can mimic basically
the a header at a lower level yeah so
you can also extract those from the
client part from the respon just by
looking at the same collection type yeah
so of course you can um do something
like this sorry you can have something
like
context dot uh response headers response
trailers to clear them and stuff like
that or we can do hey uh I want to get
the user
context and from the uh HTTP context I
want to access the the request and then
to extract things so anything that you
would do in a web API at the context
level you can do it here also because
that's not gone it's there we just add
another level below
it okay um another thing uh it's uh
related to the request headers still we
have the HTTP ones but if we want to
send data that is not part of the model
we can send it by adding metadata when
we do the call so it's like some other
uh abstraction on top of
it okay now uh some things that you
might uh tweak during development of
such service is around uh compression
algorithms you can use compression
algorithms you can use gzip you can use
uh your own compression provider if you
want uh you can say uh what is the
maximum receed message size for the grpc
so you're referring like per call yeah
so you're opening a connection and you
will have several calls grpc calls each
individual call can can be limited like
uh by using this Max receive Max send
and you say hey I'm using small data I
want to use just 20K of data do there
configure that and anything goes below
that it will break it will show an
exception so this way you can control
how how much data you're sending for
each individual
call and if we're talking uh I already
talked about this so if we're talking
about authentication types well we're
talking two places Channel
level which means that in here in the
client we can
say what are the credential types that
we can use so we can use insecure
because it's like demo environment but
we can also send claims you can add
authentication authorization in there
and you can configure what you sent
everything that is available with the
web API is available here too yeah so
for example if you want to use aure ad
or enter how is it called now you you
can also use that yeah so what it
matters is that your server knows how to
decode what authentication details
you're sending that's
it
okay so what it supported pretty much
everything
so sky is the limit every scenario is
pretty much covered um client
certificates so pfx PM FM stuff like
that jvt that's the most common scenario
in API so you can move around here um
and since we're we get this out of our
way what JPC should do awesome and when
I say should is because it doesn't do in
all situations so I have to be fair in
it so one thing that it should do asum
is the thing called grpc transcoding
yeah so long story short when you have
grpc Services uh some people will say
hey um no kend do I have apis that are
consumed internally in my system but I
also have the same API exposed to the
outside word to whatever consumer that I
don't know so I cannot go to grpc and do
that so what grpc transcoding will do is
to allow you to expose the grpc
service as a rest API rest rest API yeah
so I have here uh an API that's uh super
easy it has a service exposed with a
meth
say hello and what we do is to say hey
um I kind of want to have the option of
using a
get method uh under this pads inside my
API and if you add this along a few with
a few other things you'll be able to
call the service like internally with
GPC method say clients um say hello and
in your browser yeah because grpc
transcoding uh is able to translate HTTP
one to grpc service but in fact you
won't have like a full Communication in
from the browser to the back end just
because browser are not implementing
this standard yet if we're talking about
a frontend app or a client app that runs
in a browser talking with a grpc service
we're talking about grpc web which is a
total different implementation of it
yeah so yet we won't have uh end to end
communication using grpc we cannot yeah
so um we have this package
called grpc
transcoding that we need to
install yeah so um and another thing
that I will show you is that we can have
Swagger just as we have in rest
apis so another thing that you have to
do manually just once is to go on Google
GitHub and get this under the same
structure so there is this structure
called Google inside it's a folder
called API and inside it to protocol
files uh yeah I know you're looking
funny what this yeah I don't know uh why
they started to implement this uh this
spec transcoding that it's already
available in many languages but I think
they didn't get up to speed with the
tooling around it and you have to do
this manually grab the files put it
there and then you imported in your
protocol file definition so um in your
protocol file you'll have to say hey I'm
going to import this because I need it
because this is the thing that allows me
to uh expose this as also a different
end point which is funky yet I hoping
that I know till maybe next year given
ago they will implement this yeah so
these two files that we're asked to have
here is just a funky rule around this so
that allows us to wrap our protocol um
operations into uh things like this get
stuff like that uh patch we can also
have bodies we can also uh basically
bind parameters values from the URL uh
that's very that's very nice but let's
see it in
action so once you get all the cere
ceremony out of your way like facing the
files importing in your protocol file
installing these packages uh you would
be able to do something like this add
grpc and on top of grpc add Json trans
coding yeah so because what it happens
is is Json translated to grpc Binary and
back again yeah so this runs and
hopefully not this
this run on this specific
port
and I can do something like this I'm
going to zoom in so look what I did um I
have the Local Host this is the port uh
and I added in there a path called V1
grter and a parameter called name yeah
so instead of name I'm just going to say
hello
NDC and it gets the request
uh returns back this so looking at the
server side you'll see that it runs the
transcoding API and it gets this
executed endpoint V1 grer with a name
that gots uh that is binded from the URL
I said that the request finished it's an
http2 it's a get this time yeah so at
the browser level from the client uh we
do this time get requests yeah not not
post but those get translated uh and in
the end are um becoming binary and from
binary again so once we do this um you
realize that in fact you have grpc
service and you also have a rest service
mimicked right and what you can do is
just to add Swagger on it because that's
the way we document rest apis right so
we just add Swagger there is the
separate implementation of swagger uh
grpc Swagger as you see it's
0.3 so it's like beyond the Inception
it's just started and what it will do is
just it will scan the protocol files
look for the options and um extract
those in
the into the URL
so hopefully I can remember the Swagger
page
link going to reset the zoom yeah so
it's Swagger index HTML that's the root
the default one that I added and you
will see that the name of the service is
whatever that we added and it exposes a
get request that lives under this
specific path yeah the deal is that this
parameter here needs if you have a
complex type that you want to bind that
to it will need to be in the protocol
file type so say hey I get this and I'm
going to shove it in this specific type
that gets called to the uh grpc uh
service but if you want you also can uh
executed in here it will work just same
uh as it works for rest API yeah so this
is grpc
transcoding and also you can use like
Postman for this if you want to uh to
execute uh
grpc um I said that these are things
that supposedly go and work with grpc
supposedly uh because just when you if
you have more than one file here more
than one import and we have more
projects that use this protocol
file things will go nuts uh so that's
why I wanted to show you this and that's
why I created a separate project and not
use the the initial protocol file um
they have an issue with Imports so if
you have this import here and you're
using the same protocol file else where
the project won't build try to F found
to find solution around it but uh uh
Beyond me right now so uh this is pretty
much it with the transcoding part uh so
mindful of the time one thing that I
think I didn't show you uh and as a long
story short when it first appeared
Visual Studio was not nice at all I mean
the generated code that lives there and
usually leaves I'm going to show you
where it lives so it lives in object
debug net version and you'll see
supposedly a protocol file sorry not
here in
BBG you should see the protocol file in
there
somewhere uh the server just a sec bin
sorry object debug it should generate
the files for protos yay finally yeah so
the server generates here under this uh
wonderful folder the code that
works for us see there there are two
classes one is the type containing all
the types and one is the Grid grpc or
the service implementation that contains
the client per se yeah so if you're not
seeing this here so or something is not
right you can delete this and rebuild
the project and those will reappear um
magically running yeah so I think I told
you that with grpc you won't have code
references like like add project
reference reference the project that you
need so let me show you here in the UN
project uh looking at the dependency see
there is no project although we're using
the server yeah so how we can like make
sure that the protocol file are
accessible in here so starting 2019 and
now we have the option of right clicking
a project and we have something like add
sorry I'm going to stop
this so right click uh add connected
service it's a funny new options that we
have now so inside that connected
service it's a thing that does wonders
for us and connect
service and it will open up a screen and
inside the screen uh it will be we will
be prompted to see what reference do we
need we need an open API a grpc or WC F
web service and of course we click the
plus we select what we want to select
and of course stay away of this uh and
move and select JPC click next browse
until you find the server that's why I
told you that you should have like a
separate project where you keep the
protocol files to prevent you from doing
all kind of sped references in your code
so I'm going to the server part looking
for protocol files select grid prot to.
open and from here we have to select
what kind of things we want here so
whether we want to behave like a client
like a server like a client and a server
at the same time or we want to only the
messages I mean the types that we Define
with the keyword message which are the C
types maybe we need only those from in a
specific project and we can like help
the compiler send the right Flags to
generate only those for us yeah because
basically visual Studio doesn't do any
magic any more magic then wrap in a
visual way the executable that generates
code for C SHP that gets uh flags and
stuff like that just like net run does
you can net run no build in a similar
manner you have like protoc C flags for
CP and stuff like that it's all in their
documentation if you ever need it so um
client click finish and you'll see that
it also installs some
packages it won't install in my case but
we move on um and one thing nice about
using this is that you won't have to
think what packages do I need I am a
client so what kind of packages it's
client do whatever and what do I need it
will do it for you yeah
so this is a thing that I wanted to show
you yeah so no code references no
project references the only thing that
is common is the protocol file that
travels around yeah
okay let's see what else so done with
the grpc
transcoding uh another thing that is
really my favorite is about Transit
fault handling with the grpc call with
the channel you can say hey um in case
something bad happens you should retry
and you should retry using this policy
and that's a thing that uh it's done out
of the box with the grpc client and
without us in ining additional tools
like poly or other tool that you use for
Trans fault handling and we're going to
go here in the unary part and comment
something and uncomment some other
things so going to say hey um yep not
here where is
it am I right
place apparently I'm not here in the
right place
let's see transcoding
[Music]
API
what what
happened ype I'm going to open another
solution just for the fun of
it so we have here in the unity on the
server in here we have a thing that I
will have to
uncomment just to make sure that uh the
retries are are working so for example I
have the say hello method that in which
I will mimic that it throws an error so
how does this server knows if it's a
retry or if it's the first call to that
specific method it's just by looking at
this call grpc previous RPC attempts
this is a header that is added with the
grpc call and this is the way that the
server looks magically and say okay are
you retrying that or is the first time
you calling me yeah so I'm using this
just to mimic that something goes wrong
yeah so I'm looking if the header is
present I'm going to move on and if it's
not I'm going to throw an exception with
this particular message so I think in
the
extras fingers crossed here yeah so I
have like this I have a retry policy
that I have to configure I want maximum
two attempts I want to back off a bit uh
and I want to treat the retriable status
C is unavailable which I'm retrying and
the deadline exceeded you can pick
whatever suits your business needs um
but I'm going to just use this so you
were saying hey in case this happen so
in case you get an unavailable or you a
deadline exceeded then consider it a
retriable and just retry so what we're
going to do is to take this policy and
use it
with our
request
[Music]
and should work yeah so uh Channel with
retry so we're creating a new channel
and passing the options and that options
contain a retry policy yeah so this
might be a lot of ceremony at the
beginning but when you're calling this
from I don't know an MVC app web API or
such it's done only once in startup and
it's easier in terms of uh what you have
to configure in there so we're passing
in the channel uh to the client and
we're just calling say hello right so
I'm going to stop the server because I
think I made the
change in there going to shut it down
going to run it and build
again okay it
listens and since we don't need it this
and we don't need this so here is still
a client for a server and I'm going to
net run it it will build I'm going to
show you what
happens yes so it looks like we kind of
got the response back yeah we called we
got we got the response but look what
happened on the server
side hey server
side what anyways cool uh you see the
red
supposedly what happens show me the
error here I had to stop it yeah so I
get like this starting to receive a call
of type you it's called say hello
because that's the only method that I
had in there and I got this hey an error
was thrown and it said that is's an RPC
exception called status with this
internal status code with a detail
called not there try again yeah so
basically it retried itself without us
knowing we just saw the
response stay there yeah so we saw the
response but the client in a way is not
a word it just looks there so uh one
thing that is very nice is that it
happens transparently we just have to
configure it yeah it is there for us and
it's transparent uh and you can
configure like a retry policy if you
want or hedging policy one of or the
other but that's it yeah so um uh it's a
good practice to have such things
because if Network fails maybe second
time you try uh things will uh get
together okay so uh another thing that I
I I will show you it's around deadlines
or because I have such little time
you're going to see it uh in the
documentation what I have to show you
it's this trans fa handling out of the
box cool client side load balancing how
cool is that it's still in the library
it works so usually when you're spinning
up new server instances new API
instances uh and you have them in a load
balancer you'll have to install tools
like I don't know Linker whatever yeah
uh but this thing does this out of the
box so what I'm going to do is just to
stop the server now because the server
has that awesome uh throw exception that
we do not want and need now I'm going to
come in this out and I say hey I will
run the
server cool and then I'm going to run
another
server on the another Port yeah so I'm
going to net run at this URL and now
going to have two server instances
waiting yeah uh it's waiting on this
port and the first console Waits on this
port cool enough um let's run the
client fingers crossed it got a hello
back from 5,000 in one cool I'm going to
run it
again run it again I
said w
there is a small catch let's
see
so yeah there is the catch that I have
to stop this and use the second one
because there's a different example so
uh request new request and this is the
one DNS resolver practice channel
channel channel channel
yes so basically now when we're running
the client it will know to balance bance
itself using a balancing uh policy that
we said there you can have like round
robin
5,000 5,000 in1 I
said what let's look at the
policy again so we're saying like this
we have to have a balancer address we
have a server that runs here and a
server that runs here so we have a
factory we take the
Factory and we created a channel by
passing it in round robin config the
channel is called the Channel and then
we're going to
say that we get the channel pass it
in and we should get back the thing
H it looks fine to me at
least and it let's check if the both so
this
runs 5,000
run the second
instance 5,000 And1
listens cool let's see again fingers
crossed if not is
documented No it should be like getting
this different uh the different uh Port
back from here
sorry am I no it's just STS because the
console executes rights and stops and
the next time that I'm I'm going
[Music]
to
yes I didn't pray enough to the demo
Gods so uh you see it balances itself I
don't really know how that happens but
it happens and it's awesome because
whenever you want want to have a new
instance you can create a policy either
to pick first and just pass it on the
round robin or maybe why not Implement
something like three times here two
times there and throw an exception and
back again yeah so uh I'm way above my
time uh thank you for uh listening uh I
have the resources like
here so you can download the repo and
play around um I'll be around if you
have any
questions uh thank you for being here I
know it was a lot of uh grpc hanging
around so thank you for having me
here